thank you looks like I'm lucky in there
some Cubs fans here today let's just get
that important stuff out of the way
right now how many Cubs fans are here
and how many Red Sox fans are here and
last how many Yankee fans are here I see
Yankee fans the exits are just around
back right out Phelps gate and keep
walking
president salivate heads of college
college Dean's members of the faculty
and staff good afternoon members of the
class council class day chairs Joanna
and Larry class secretary Tommy and
class treasurer and Mimi in the entire
yellow class of 2017 greetings and
congratulations I'm honored to be with
you here today to help celebrate and I'd
like to thank Joanna and Larry for
inviting me on behalf of the whole class
and for that to kind introduction thank
you your class has been witnessed to and
a participant in a period of historic
change here at Yale the inauguration of
a new president the creation of two new
residential colleges the renaming of a
third and perhaps most savory of all the
introduction of Hanoi fried capes arcs
at University diner
[Applause]
and I would like to recognize some of
the members of your class who had
special accomplishments this year as
Joanna and Larry mentioned the Yale
baseball team for just this week
winning the Ivy League and returning to
the NCAA tournament for the first time
since 1994 congratulations guys
also the women's swimming team winning
the Ivy's for the first time in twenty
years and as previously mentioned the
yell football team first time in ten
years beating Harvard where to go pull
it off and last but not least say Brooke
for just uh I I watched the game this
year
[Applause]
that's just an unprecedented commitment
to the Saybrook strip that was I think I
remember back in my day we like kept our
underwear on and didn't get hauled off
by Harvard police but thank you thank
you for taking it to the next level that
is what we call progress I'd also like
to thank some others who are here today
in support first of all my family
including my father Leslie class of 60
and my sister Anja class of 92 I know
despite your great faith in me that
you're a little surprised and I'm the
one up here today next some of my
friends and classmates at Yale who are
here today with whom I discovered the
great institutions of higher learning
Toad's place and Rudy's and wasted more
than our share of brain cells in pursuit
of the knowledge hidden there I know you
are shocked as I am about this honor
here today and finally a nod to my
professors and especially my terrific
graduate student teaching assistants
thank you all for your invaluable
tutelage I know you were somewhat
bemused that I made it to my own class
day so you've got to be downright
horrified that I'm the one out there
today I do remember my years that Yale
very fondly and as you'll find out a
Yale degree is something that stays with
you the rest of your life back in 2002
when at 28 years old I stumbled into
becoming general manager of the Red Sox
days after I was hired my boss Larry
Luke Eno was visiting an old baseball
colleague of his president george w bush
class of 68 in the White House President
Bush asked what are you doing naming a
28 year old as general manager because
that's far too young that's that's an
third risk looky no replied no no mr.
president you don't understand
he's a Yale man to which the president
replied strike two
like the former president I didn't do
anything too serious in my career I just
I just worked in baseball yes America's
national pastime but also largely just
part of the bread and circuses of
society entertaining and distracting us
while others like my twin brother Paul
who's here today a social worker do the
real work of holding our communities
together but there are certainly times
when baseball is much more than bread
and circus times when baseball resonates
deeply and meaning meaningfully for many
many people in times when a game that is
built around overcoming failure can
teach us all a few important lessons so
class of 2017 if you'll indulge me I'm
going to tell just one baseball story
it's a bit long but you'll like the
ending unless you're from Cleveland in
which case I'm deeply sorry the story is
about a very important game game seven
last year's World Series but in as
little to do with the actual outcome of
the game for those who don't follow
baseball a little quick backgrounds I
work for the Chicago Cubs
a team with the following so loyal and
adoring in the history so forlorn that
we were known nationwide as the lovable
losers as of last fall the Cubs did not
won a World Series since 1908 think
about that 1908
that's the Teddy Roosevelt
administration the Ottoman Empire was
still around and kicking
that two world wars ago way to say I
actually haven't checked the news since
breakfast let's give me one second
good news it's still just two world wars
ago all in all it was a 108 year drought
the longest in the history of
professional sports as the late cubs
broadcasting legend Jack Brickhouse used
to say anybody can have a bad century I
joined the Cubs in 2011 amid an
inordinate and uncomfortable amount of
media attention the Chicago sun-times I
remember ran a full page front page
photo shop of me walking on water across
Lake Michigan as if by showing up I was
going to miraculously turn around the
team's fortunes imagine their
disappointment then when one year in 100
and 101 losses later
I'm sorry imagine their disappointment
then when I announced immediately a
long-term rebuilding plan built around
acquiring young players and built around
winning five years down the line so one
season and 101 losses later the same
paper ran the identical photo of me but
this time the only thing above water was
the tip of my nose one day in the early
years with the Cubs after a particularly
humiliating double-digit loss at home at
Wrigley I was walking home amongst the
fans in a bit of a foul mood and I
remember I had my head down trying not
to get recognized a very charming
elderly woman recognized me she spotted
me and she came over to ask a question
she said I appreciate what you were
trying to do young man I really do I
understand why you're bringing in so
many young players but tell me exactly
when are you planning on winning the
World Series I'm not sure how much time
I have left so I was a little taken
aback and all I could think of to say as
I put my head back down to walk away was
ma'am I hope you take your vitamins walk
away that was five years ago but if it
happened today I'd probably say ma'am I
hope you don't have any pre-existing
conditions
[Applause]
so after three years of arduous
rebuilding we had a nucleus of young
players at the Cubs we believed in who
are ready to break into the majors
together many of these players are 21 22
years old your peers your generation
typically it takes young players years
to adjust to life in the big leagues and
to start playing up to their
capabilities most of the blame for this
rests on these ridiculous old baseball
norms that say young players are to be
seen and not heard that young players
must follow and not lead the young
players must adhere to the established
codes from the dress code that requires
them to wear suits and ties to the
coaches as major league players can't
get too excited or look like they're
having too much fun out there on the
field thankfully we hired a manager in
Joe Maddon who agreed it was time to
turn these conventions on their heads we
asked our young players to be themselves
to show their personalities to have fun
to be daring to be bold the dress code
was changed from suit and tie to if you
think you look hot wear it
unburdens and empowered our young team
flourish last season winning 103 games
the most in all baseball and reaching
our first World Series since 1945 after
fighting back from a three games to one
deficit to the Cleveland Indians we
faced a decisive Game seven in Cleveland
I watched Game seven from the stands
with my colleagues my wife Marie and my
oldest son Jack who was then eight years
old
Jack a big baseball fan and the math
whiz of the family kept me updated on
the Cubs win probability throughout the
course of the game so as we enjoyed a
two-run lead after five innings he
tapped me on the leg dad we have a 67
percent chance of winning the World
Series I know buddy it's going well but
remember it's baseball and lots of
things can happen
it's all I can think of to say so later
we had a three-run lead with just four
outs to go in the game nobody on base
and the bottom of the Indians order
coming to the plate tens of millions of
Cubs fans nationwide counting down the
outs put their arms around loved ones or
called them to keep them close for the
big moment ahead Jack put his arm around
me that we have a 97% chance to win the
World Series I know buddy I know it's so
great that one batter at a time we still
need four more outs if we don't want to
look too far ahead but that first time
in 108 years
just then out of nowhere as storm clouds
moved into the area an infield single a
double an errant fastball a fateful
swing in a possible homerun in a tie
game Indians fans erupted rocking the
stadium on its foundations you're
splitting tears Cubs fans and I slumped
in our seats heads in hands just then I
felt another top of my leg dad
we definitely have less than a 50%
chance of winning the World Series now I
[Applause]
couldn't think of anything wise to say
so I just sat up in my seat stared stoic
ly out at the field put one arm around
my son and with the other I tapped his
hand he capped his leg as reassuringly
as I could minutes later the skies
opened up and rain halted the action it
was just enough of a pause to ponder the
magnitude of the situation extra innings
in Game seven of the World Series an
entire season down to this one moment a
five-year plan down to this one moment
and for Cubs fans 108 years of patience
and unrequited love down to one moment
still in a bit of a daze that cut
through our Clubhouse towards the
meeting about the weather turning a
corner I saw through the window of the
weight room door the backs of our
players jerseys blue jerseys
shoulder-to-shoulder packed tightly all
25 guys squeezed into a space designed
for about half that many it was an
unusual sight we hardly ever had
meetings never during a game I inch
closer to the door and saw a roll just
Chapman the pitcher had given up the
game-tying homerun in tears I lingered
just long enough to hear a few sentences
we would not even be here without you
catcher David Ross says said as he
embraced Chapman we're going to win this
for you we're going to win this for each
other
outfielder jason heyward walked to the
middle of the room we are the best team
in baseball he said we've leaned on each
other all year we've still got this this
is only going to make it sweeter and
then first baseman Anthony Rizzo nobody
can take this away from us we have each
other
Kyle schwarber stood up with a bat in
his hands we win this right here he said
I turned away a big smile on my face and
headed to that weather meeting ten
minutes later the rain cleared schwöre
BER let off with a single Zobrist
doubled just past the reach of the third
baseman and we took the lead in the
bottom of the tenth of the tying run on
base and the winning run at the plate at
12:47 a.m.
Kris Bryant fields a slow roller with a
gigantic smile on his face and through
to Rizzo for the final out the custard
won the World Series
[Applause]
not to be a front-runner but my wife
Jack and I embraced and celebration
equal parts ecstasy and relief
I noticed Jack's mouth a gape the young
mathematician was shocked and overjoyed
that we had for once beaten the odds
later that morning back in Wrigley the
team bus passed a cemetery on the ride
from O'Hare to Wrigley back in Chicago
we saw countless Cubs hats and pennants
already draped lovingly over tombstones
for family members who did not quite
live to see the moment the next day five
million triumphant Chicagoans from every
corner of the immense city gathered
downtown for a victory parade the seed
of blue was a beautiful sight
Chicago fractious and endangered was
united in the aftermath of the
championship after all the champagne had
dried and we finally got a good night's
sleep
I found myself returning to one simple
question what should I tell Jack and his
younger brother drew about this historic
achievement what was it exactly that I
wanted them to hold on to I thought
immediately of the players meeting
during the rain delay and how connected
they were with each other how invested
they were in each others face how they
turned each other's tears into
determination during rain delays players
typically come in off the field and head
to their own lockers they sit there by
themselves they change the wet jerseys
they check their phones they think about
what's gone right and wrong during the
game they become engrossed in their own
little worlds that would have been
disastrous for our team during Game
seven twenty-five players sitting alone
at their lockers lamenting the bad
breaks assigning blame wallowing
wondering instead they have the instinct
to come together actually it was not an
instinct it was a choice one day I will
tell Jack and drew that some players and
some of us go through our careers with
their heads down focused on our craft in
our
keeping to ourselves worrying about our
numbers or our grades pursuing the next
objective goal building our resumes
projecting our individual interest other
players and others amongst us go through
our careers with their heads up as a
real part of a team alert and aware of
others embracing difference employing
empathy genuinely connecting putting
collective interests ahead of our own it
is a choice the former approach keeping
our head down seems safer and more
efficient and I guess sometimes it is
the latter connecting keeping our heads
up allows us to lead and every now and
then to be part of something much
greater than ourselves and therefore to
truly triumph I know I will tell them
because I've tried it both ways and I'll
tell Jack and Drew that we all have our
rain delay moments there will be times
when everything you've been wanting
everything you have worked for
everything you have earned everything
you feel you deserve it snatched away in
what seems like a personal and unfair
blow this I will tell them it's called
life but when these moments happen and
they will will you be alone that's your
locker with your head down lamenting
giving up blame or will you be shoulder
to shoulder with your teammates
connected with your heads up giving and
receiving support and I will tell them
not to wait until the rain comes to make
this choice because that can be too late
we weren't winners that night in
Cleveland guess we ended up with one
more run than the Indians if Zobrist
ball had been four inches farther off
the line that double would have been a
double play and we would have lost the
game that was randomness like much of
life it was arbitrary
we were winners that night in Cleveland
because when things went really really
wrong and then when the rains came our
players already knew each other so well
that they could come together they
already trusted each other
so much that they can open up and be
vulnerable and they already were so
connected that they could lift one
another up we got already one that's why
I had that smile on my face as I walked
away from the weight room door I later
learned that the players only meeting
had been called by Hayward a 27 year old
suffering through a terrible offensive
season by far the worst of his career
most players who are having seasons that
rough detached themselves from the team
either head to the disabled list or at
the periphery of the clubhouse isolate
themselves but Hayward stayed at the
center of everything he never stopped
being invested in his teammates he
opened up to them about the struggles he
bought some sweets on the road for
gathering the first to speak in the
meeting was Ross the 38 year old backup
catcher in his final season who made a
career out of being a wonderful teammate
and by the way is now in the finals of
Dancing with the Stars you thought you
were having a good year
Ross he was always reaching out to
befriend the loneliest players always
organizing team dinners always breaking
down the barriers that sometimes arise
between players of different backgrounds
in the clubhouse the last to speak at
the meeting was Rizzo the young team
leader who all season long was reminding
his teammates that they were going to
make history together they were going to
have a parade and then be linked in
eternity forever Anthony a survivor of
pediatric cancer just celebrated the
World Series by making a three and a
half million dollar gift to Chicago's
lurie Children's Hospital
Harbor who had the bat in his hands and
raced out of the meeting into the
batter's box had torn two ligaments in
his knee in the third game of the season
the 12th the 15-month injury rather than
disappearing to a rehab facility
schwarmann ears old stayed connected
with the team getting his rehab work
done early in the morning so the
teammates didn't have to see him in that
state and then functioning as an extra
coach for his teammates the rest of the
day he kept telling his teammates he was
going to find a way to be there for them
find a way to help them win shocking the
doctors and everyone else
schwarber returned in just six months
right in time for the World Series he
hit 400 over 400 in the World Series
including that single to start the
deciding rally in Game seven so early in
my career I used to think of players as
a depth statistics on a spreadsheet I
could use to project future performance
and measure precisely how much they were
going to impact our team on the field I
used to think of teams as portfolios
diversify collections of player assets
paid to produce up to their projections
to ensure the organization's success my
head had been down that narrow approach
worked for a while
but it certainly had its limits I drew
and my team building philosophy grew as
well the truth as our team proved in
Cleveland is that a player's character
matters the heart beat matters fears and
aspirations matter the players impact on
others matters the tone he sets matters
the willingness to connect matters
breaking down cliques and overcoming
stereotypes in the clubhouse matters who
you are how you live among others that
all matters the youngest team in World
Series history six starters under the
age of 25 they helped me get my head up
that is why
at the important moments in their lives
I'm going to keep telling my sons about
the 2016 Cubs and that rain delay and
I'll remind them when they're graduating
college we're starting a new job heading
off to grad school or beginning a new
life somewhere foreign that they have a
choice so class of 2017 as someone who
has already been uplifted by members of
your generation I am thankful and really
in awe of what you all can accomplish
when given the space to be free to let
your personalities out and to figure it
out
I'm truly inspired by the traits that
distinguish your generation your
diversity your boldness your optimism
your tolerance your treatment of others
based on substance rather than on the
labels that used to divide us I am so
excited to see what lies ahead for you
all while there will undoubtedly be
times here and there when you have to
suck it up follow the code put on that
suit and tie I urge you to remember that
if you think you look hot wear it
and and please remember that even though
so much can be quantified these days the
most important things cannot be and
finally when things go really really
wrong and then when it rains on top of
everything else fingers crossed for
tomorrow I ask you to choose to keep
your heads up and come together to
connect and to rally around one another
especially those who need it the most it
is likely to uplift you all thank you
and congratulations
[Music]